for eight hours he'd climbed through the
skeletal ribs of the ship
attaching conduit installing replacement
maneuvering thrusters
patching holes he didn't know how to do
everything that needed to be done but he
wanted to
so he shattered the technicians doing
the really complicated work it all felt
very normal
very routine almost like still having
his old life but then he'd returned to
his apartment eight hours later and no
one would be there
he was truly alone for the first time in
years amos wouldn't come by
asking him to hit a bar alex wouldn't
watch the video stream
sitting on his couch and making
sarcastic comments to the screen
naomi wouldn't be there to ask about his
day and compare notes on how the repairs
were coming the rooms even smelled empty
it wasn't something about himself he'd
ever had to face before but holden was
coming to realize
how much he needed family hey guys pete
here
it's a little late but as there doesn't
seem to be a
episode 4 trailer today i thought i'd do
a quick video about what comes next in
the expanse season 5.
you can expect spoilers for everything
that's happened in the expanse tv show
through season 5 episode 3. i've read
all the books
and i will be referring to them but i
won't give away any future spoilers that
come from there
with all that said let's get into it
episode 3
ended with a major event a giant
asteroid crashed to earth's surface
and there's been a lot of discussion
online about how big this might
be how it'll compare to what happened in
the books at this point i think it's
best to avoid speculating
and keep things sort of general this is
not an insignificant
event and it goes beyond the actual
damage from the impact
now of course we know that there are
more of these things aimed at earth and
coming its way
we don't know if they'll hit or not but
if you look at things
on the scale of terrorism terrorism not
only to take
millions or hundreds of millions of
lives which this most likely will do
but also to produce fear no one on
planet earth will be able to feel safe
in the aftermath of this
it's unprecedented in its scale as far
as we can tell
in the audacity of going after
humanity's home planet
marco inaros's plan seems to be working
and we will get back to him when we talk
about naomi but for now let's check in
with some of the other characters
including avasarala who has figured out
that he's behind it
in the first three episodes we saw that
she pieced together that marco had
thrown
a stealth covered rock at earth the
private sector scientists confirmed her
suspicions
she got further confirmation when fred
johnson sent her the recording of marco
talking from ashford
but she's stuck in a situation with
politics being as they
are no one will listen to her and
there's nothing she can do
i'd say most of what we've seen from her
so far is character development showing
us where she's at
she wasn't able to prevent the first
rock from hitting but the information
she's gathered and what she's doing with
bobby will likely play
an important role in going after marco
after the fact
she's on luna so the character who's
closest to ground
zero right now is actually amos amos is
on earth he didn't really show up in
episode three but at the end of episode
two we saw he finished his business
looking into what happened to lydia
at the end of that he reached out to
sarala and told her he was never coming
back to earth but there was one person
he wanted to see and he needed her help
to arrange that
this is one of those things that i
definitely know who he's talking about
if you've read the books you know as
well if you've been paying close
attention you might also know
but otherwise it's something i really
can't touch i think what's more
important here is that he is on the
planet and will be in a position to
experience that the
aftermath in a way that no one else will
humanity's home is under attack
and i opened the video with an excerpt
from a holden chapter from nemesis games
where he's feeling separated from the
crew and realizing how important they
are to him
and how much he needs a family many of
the stories for the characters in this
season
is going back and facing the past in
that process holden is feeling separated
he's lonely there at tycho but he's also
found himself in the middle of what's
going on there as well with fred johnson
it's clear that somebody is working
against their interests on the station
there's a mole
monica is keeping the idea of the
proto-molecule in the story
and this is actually changed somewhat
from the book so i'm not exactly sure
what they're doing but with her
showing the video of paolo cortazar
being abducted by
belters and then anderson dawes
confirming that that happened on series
does hint that there's a bigger
conspiracy going on
than just throwing a couple of asteroids
at the earth keep in mind that
holden did lie to monica when she asked
him about the proto-molecule
she asked him if he kept a sample which
he didn't the rossi crew
actually gave the sample they had to
fred johnson
and in the first episode we saw that
fred mentioned that he still has it
and no he won't give it up as far as
monica's abduction
that seems to be a coordinated effort by
someone
fred bull and holden have a plan to
catch some of the conspirators when they
try to come pick up the container that
monica's supposed to be in
but without knowing where loyalties lie
inside the station itself
it's hard to speculate on what's going
on there elsewhere in the belt we have
drummer who we've seen
is working in piracy she's entered into
a polyamorous
family they now have three ships and
after finding ashfordship the tynan
drummer decided that she wanted to go
after marco for the bounty
one of the things i saw in discussions
about the episodes was
some people thought it was out of
character for drummer to become a pirate
and i can say that i kind of understand
where people are coming from
but if you think back to her arc in
season 4 it does
track remember she quit working for fred
johnson at medina station
she thought his decision to work with
the inners got dozens of belters killed
and that marco was going to be able to
use that to rally
thousands of belters to his side and
where drummer's going is always hard to
figure out because she's a combination
of different characters from the books
but i think where they're going for here
is that she's looking for independence
she followed anderson dawes
she followed fred johnson those
experiences led her to be disillusioned
and now she's found this new family and
she decided to stay out of politics
they're pirates and she decided to sign
on with them she did make the decision
to pass the information
to fred johnson that ashford had
recorded but she did that with a caveat
that it wasn't her
fight going forward it'll be interesting
to see if she still wants to go after
marco
and what effect that has on her new
family situation
as we saw through oxana that the crew
isn't 100 on board with the idea
our final story in the belt is naomi in
the first three episodes we saw her
arrive at palace station where she
realized that philip is in too
deep with marco in the free navy that
realization came way too late
as she's basically now been taken
hostage there was a lot going on with
her interactions with her
old crewmates sin and coral and then her
finally talking to her son
after all this time she has no idea
what's going on yet but philip's
decision to take her back
is gonna put her in a really crazy
situation
i think we could say for sure after
watching the season five trailer that
marco is going to take responsibility
for the rock hitting earth
phillip played an active role in the
planning and
he's complicit in this event now naomi
is going to be with them which isn't a
great place to be when all this goes
down
but it's also a really interesting
situation because what they're doing is
a massive attack they are intending to
kill a lot of people there's really no
way that anybody could justify this but
what's interesting about naomi
is that she understands how marco
operates
she knows how he manipulates people and
she knows this firsthand because of the
august and gamora
and what he did there that was his first
big attack
and he had her write the code making her
complicit and when she wasn't all right
with that
that's when he took philip away so you
have a mother who's looking at her son
knowing he's involved with these things
that he's an active participant but she
also has an
understanding of marco so it's going to
be hard for her to separate that from
the reality of what's going on plus she
hasn't seen marco for years
they're gonna be in a way reunited and
that's gonna bring all of that stuff
back up to the surface as well
a lot of interesting stuff going on with
naomi and her story
to round out the rest of the characters
we have alex and bobby on mars
bobby has made a lot of progress for
abasarala looking into all these black
market weapon deals
and she's landed on sobiter as her main
suspect
alex wasn't able to get close to him but
he did have dinner with emily babbage
she was really focused on the
proto-molecule and his experience on
illus
she has some very pointed questions and
he went along as that was their strategy
him and bobby talked about it before he
went and thought that he should
entertain her questions and then try to
figure out some things about soviet era
in the process
and while i went over all of that in my
breakdown video
for the first three episodes we could
tell that something's going on with
these two babbage and soviter
we can guess that it's likely connected
to what bobby found in her investigation
with all the weapons
and we know they're leaving mars on a
ship called the bar keith
i think the other really interesting
part here is that
after his dinner he was immediately
attacked by these other people wondering
why he was asking about soviter that
paints the picture that there's a bigger
conspiracy going on
as well and makes you wonder about the
behind the scenes stuff
which feels a lot like what's happening
at taiko at the same time
and we know it all boils down to the
ring gates opening this has turned
everything on its head
people are looking to get colony ships
together they're racing out to be the
first to get to this planet or the next
we saw recruitment signs behind alex
when he was on the shuttle
so there's a lot going on and that
presents opportunities for people to try
to grab
power and i think that's a good place to
leave it i said i was going to make a
quick video and it still
looks like it's probably about 10
minutes but let me know in the comments
what you think's going on
if you've read the books please mark any
book spoilers accordingly
don't give up the game let me know how
you think everything's going to play out
where things are heading also let me
know what you think about this format
i was out of town this weekend on a trip
that was planned a long time ago so i
didn't really get to do any bonus
material
so i'm curious to see what you guys want
if i do this again next week i'll do it
much
sooner instead of waiting to the day
before the next episode comes out but
i'm open to suggestions
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon